when apple revealed the apple watch
series 7 during their event it basically
blew everyone's mind because we were all
expecting a new flat and boxy design but
apple came out and did the complete
opposite they made it more rounded than
ever before and this obviously caused a
lot of drama because jon prosser and ian
zelbo were banking on this new boxy
design and they received a ton of hate
comments because they got it wrong and
their response to the actual design was
that they were absolutely confused with
what the heck happened with the boxy
design apparently they actually saw
multiple leaked images from various
sources of the flat sides so they were
certain that it was going to end up
being the final design even i was 100
sure that this would be the design of
the series 7 because the actual cad
files of the design were leaked and they
perfectly matched up to the renders that
ian zelba created on top of that
multiple sources in the supply chain
agreed on the new boxy design and even
mark german himself corroborated the new
flat sides and he's probably the most
reliable apple leaker out there and
what's incredibly weird is that mark
german previously reported that the
display would be flatter not more
rounded like apple just did with the
series 7. he even said that it would
feature a new lamination technique to
bring the display closer to the front
cover glass which makes sense for a boxy
design but no apple actually made it
further away by increasing the thickness
of the glass which doesn't seem to make
sense and on top of that mark also
mentioned that it would receive new
internals including a faster processor
but nope we didn't get that either he
also mentioned that the series 7 would
have updated ultra wideband technology
but no apple didn't mention anything
about that in a few days before the
event ming chikuo mentioned that the key
selling point of the series 7 is the
dramatic change in design which is the
most significant change ever with the
flat edge and narrow bezel design and
that's obviously not what we got so what
in the world happened well there's a
theory going around that apple
completely fooled all of the leakers by
putting out the boxycat files to weed
out the leak sources but that is
actually false and i'm gonna prove it to
you in this video because of all the
weirdness surrounding the series 7's
design i decided to do some
investigative journalism and i can now
confirm that apple had to cancel the
boxy design of the series 7 at the last
minute and scramble for a new solution
just before the event and this story
begins with the weirdness surrounding
the event and release day for the first
time ever apple revealed the watch
without giving us an official release
date they simply said later this fall
which is incredibly weird and even worse
for the first time ever they didn't give
us any text specs at all on their
website so i ended up doing a ton of
research on twitter and i found
something completely shocking the apple
developer steve trout and smith was
digging through the code and discovered
why apple didn't talk about the chip
this year apparently that's because it
uses the same s6 chip as last year's
model the series 7 apparently doesn't
even get a new model number it's still
listed as t-8301
which has never happened before and this
means that the internals are basically
identical apple simply tweaked the
chassis and that's it and another
developer galerme rambo believes that
the leakers were actually right all
along but something went wrong at the
last minute and it was too late to be
fixed so apple had to improvise and this
brings us to a wild chain of leaks that
explain the entire situation that
occurred with the series 7. on august
31st we received a report from nikkei
asia that the apple watch series 7
production has been delayed due to
quality issues apparently small scale
production began the week prior and they
encountered critical challenges and
reaching satisfactory production
performance and this next detail that
they in this next detail and this next
detail that they shared is about to be
the nail in the coffin for this video
three sources said that the current
disappointing production quality could
be attributed to the complexity of
design which is quote
significantly different than that of
previous generations of the watch and
the assemblers found issues when putting
together electronics modules components
and displays
just take a look at the design of the
new series 7 and tell me that it looks
significantly different because it
doesn't it's almost exactly the same
design now these renders of a boxy
design
look significantly different and that's
why i think made them run into all of
those issues now another thing the
report mentioned is that they had
trouble putting the different components
together and the only way that would
make sense is if the entire layout was
changed and redesigned completely in
fact the faster s7 chip was leaked for a
while now in the supply chain including
by mark german himself and it was even
rumored to come with a new double-sided
design which was meant to provide space
for a larger battery and other
components but guess what mac rumors
just came out and confirmed that the
series 7 will come with a rebranded s7
chip package which is literally
identical to the s6 chip in terms of the
cpu layout the performance the same 32
gigs of storage the same bluetooth 5.0
spec and the same u1 ultra wide band
chip and this totally goes against
everything that mark german said about
the s7 so what if there is actually an
s7 ship somewhere out there that is
faster and features a double-sided chip
design which was destined for the new
boxy watch design because if you think
about it that new design would require
apple to completely rearrange all of the
internal parts and if that is true then
the battery design would also need to be
changed and potentially be made larger
which is what a lot of the other leaks
were pointing to a larger battery even
max weinbach said that the series 7
would get the biggest battery life
improvement since the original apple
watch but nope apple said that the
series 7 gets the same all day 18 hours
of battery life as it did before kind of
pointing to apple reusing the exact same
battery from the series 6 which the
identical model numbers basically
confirm so i ended up going on apple's
website and i tried to find what has
actually changed or improved with the
series 7 and there were only 5 things
the new color options the larger 41 and
45 millimeter display panels that are
now brighter the slightly redesigned
speaker ports the more rounded top cover
glass and the charging architecture that
is now faster that's it nothing else has
changed so i got to thinking and i
realized that the charging system is
completely irrelevant to the design of
the watch because apple had to make sure
that you can reuse the old charging
pucks that are included in many
third-party accessories like this
expensive three-in-one charging stand so
i ended up reading the entire apple
watch series 7 product page on apple's
website and everything else that apple
showed off was related to software
features including the new apple watch
faces so from an internals and specs
standpoint the series 7 is basically
identical to the series 6 so it kind of
proves that apple actually had to scrap
the real series 7 at the last moment and
improvise a totally new solution and
guess what just a couple of days before
the event it was confirmed that apple
overcame the series 7 manufacturing
issues and they would apparently be
starting mass production sometime this
month with the supply of series 7
improving significantly from mid to late
october and this finally brings us to
the craziest leak yet shrimp apple pro a
lesser-known leaker posted a thread
showing a new apple watch label for the
series 7 with a new 41 millimeter
display however he mentioned that the
series 7 would actually still have a
round design like the series 6 but with
thinner bezels now at first i didn't
believe him especially since he was
saying that his source was going against
prosser who actually saw real life
photos but he ended up being completely
right all along and just this morning he
actually confirmed that the apple watch
series 7 production will begin next week
which is ironic because that's usually
when customers already have a new watch
model in their hands so with that said
if you're still confused on how all of
this could happen let me break it all
down for you late last month apple began
mass production for the real series 7
but they ran into issues with putting
all of the components together like
nikkei asia reported on august 31st so
apple scrambled to figure out what they
could do to resolve the issues and still
ship a new apple watch this year which
is what all of their investors are
expecting but here is where the massive
problems began the new s7 chip with the
totally redesigned double-sided package
has already been produced in mass
numbers and it doesn't fit in the series
6 design so they had to scrap the new
chip and go back to the s6 chat but
making it even worse apple already mass
produced the new 41 and 45 millimeter
display panels that were now meant to be
used alongside a new flat cover glass
design which would perfectly fit the new
boxy series 7 design that we saw in the
renders on top of that apple already
created new watch faces to take
advantage of the larger displays and
they also created the new keyboard
feature which works because of the
larger displays so they would have to
scrap all of that as well but here is
the absolute worst part of all something
that they could not scrap according to
majin buu on twitter apple had already
started mass production of their new
series 7 watch bands on august 26th or
sooner and the crazy part about that is
that the band itself shows a 41
millimeter text on the edge and another
leak showed a leather band with a 45
millimeter text on it so at that point
since many of the bands were already
produced including the handmade hermes
bands apple couldn't just go back to the
old 40 and 44 millimeter display panels
with the old looking design and if they
actually ended up doing just that there
would essentially be nothing different
at all about the new series 7 except for
some new color options which would be
absolutely catastrophic
since everyone on the internet is
expecting a full square redesign so here
is what apple did in the short couple of
weeks between the discovery of the
production issues and the announcement
from ming chi kuo that the issues have
been solved just a few days before the
actual event happened apple scrambled to
figure out a way to integrate the new 41
and 45 millimeter display panels into
the old series 6 design with all of its
internals and everything else but the
major issue is that the new display
panels simply wouldn't fit inside of the
current cover glass that the series 6 is
using because it's already at its
physical limits so here is how apple did
it because apple had to scrap the boxy
redesign instead of making the flatter
display closer to the front cover glass
like mark german leaked they ended up
completely changing the front cover
glass and giving it a completely flat
base to match the already manufactured
flat display panels and to make those
new display panels actually fit they had
to pack them slightly deeper into the
watch itself which required them to
redesign the cover glass and make it 50
thicker with a much more rounded shape
so that you could actually see the full
larger display and then to match the new
more rounded cover glass they also had
to slightly redesign the metal chassis
to make it more round to match up flush
with the glass which obviously required
them to tweak their existing
manufacturing tooling for the new
rounded design and that perfectly
explains why apple didn't give us any
release date at all just simply saying
later this fall because they didn't know
how long it would take them to replicate
the new tooling on more production lines
and get mass production going at full
speed so basically it turns out that
completely scrapping the real series 7
was apple's solution to the production
issues they were able to keep the
already produced larger display panels
they kept the already produced apple
watch bands they kept the new larger
watch faces and the keyboard feature and
they still gave us a new design the only
downside is that they had to scrap all
of the new internals including the
faster double-sided s7 chip the larger
battery that was leaked the updated
ultra wide band chip that mark german
leaked and obviously much more so if
you're gonna tell me that apple did all
of this just to crack down on leaks and
embarrass jon prosser and ian's elbow i
don't believe you apple holding back on
a release date and official tech specs
absolutely hurts them and these delays
are actually really bad for apple's
bottom line because they're losing out
on quarterly sales numbers the longer
they wait to ship the watch and just the
fact that last year apple held a
september event and released the apple
watch on time instead of waiting until
the delayed iphone event in october goes
to show how important it is for apple to
not delay the watch and boom that was
the last nail in the coffin everything i
just mentioned in this video basically
confirms that the leakers weren't wrong
at all apple actually had to scrap the
boxy series 7 at the last minute and
somehow improvise a new solution while
making it seem like nothing happened so
with that said i honestly feel like jon
prosser and ian zelbo deserve a pass on
this one so stop giving them a hard time
because of apple's production freak
accident and let's all hope we get the
real flat sided series 7 with the faster
chip next year with the series 8. and to
finish off this crazy video leaks apple
pro explained it in the perfect way
apple had to go back to the old design
because of problems with the new one
that's why there's nothing new that's
why it has the same cpu the same model
number and it's taking longer to ship
the leakers were right so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click that circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out our new merch
like our classic apple product icon
shirt down in the merch shelf below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you